donnée par ce cabinet qui a été chargé
de les mettre en oeuvre au sein de
l'état et dans quel calendrier est
autrement dit ces conseils sont ils
d'ores et déjà appliquée où sont ils en
passe de l'être
donc monsieur ministre voici la première
question et ensuite nous aurons une
vingtaine de questions
madame la présidente de la commission
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
laissez-moi vous souhaitez d'abord de
mes meilleurs voeux à mon tour en ce
début d'année je me réjouis d'être de
votre devant votre commission et
j'aurais fort évidemment de me ferai
fort de répondre rapidement aux
questions dans cette espèce de des
changes direct que vous avez souhaité
installer ce qui me va très bien
le cabinet mckinsey mais avant lui
d'autres cabinets d'ailleurs c'est un
système de carrousel qui est mis en
place dans le cadre du soutien de
l'action de l'état par des cabinets
privés c'était extrêmement classique et
c'est le cas en france et partout
ailleurs en europe nous appuie dans la
conduite du projet en lien avec la task
force la force d'action qui est en
charge de mettre en place toute la
stratégie logistique donc le cabinet ne
vous êtes dans la stratégie vaccinale
pratiques opérationnelles dans les
enjeux de logistique mais également dans
les travaux de comparaison de ce qu'on
appelle le benchmark en afrique anglais
international puisque c'est un cabinet
qui a aussi vocation à conseiller
d'autres bien d'autres ministère de la
santé dans l'application des stratégies
vaccinales dont je les remercie de leur
aide nous avons tout intérêt à utiliser
toutes les compétences dont nous
disposons dans notre pays qu'elles
soient publiques ou privées et je vous
remercie d'avoir dit que cela ne vous
inquiète pas vous-même en tout cas ça me
choque absolument pas et c'est la
tradition d'ailleurs de votre état que
de fonctionner ainsi
ça c'est le début mais ma question
c'était surtout quels conseils vous ont
été données et comment sont ils
actuellement appliquée à écouter ce sont
des conseils extrêmement varié avec
beaucoup de travail au contact des par
exemple des 100 hôpitaux pivot il faut
sans arrêt les appelait les solliciter
pour vérifier que les livraisons de
vaccins de seringue d'aiguilhe se
déroule dans les bonnes conditions il ya
toute la chaîne logistique entre les
plateformes logistiques du flux à les
plateformes du flux b le centre de santé
publique france vraiment c'est du
travail de j'allais dire du travail de
fourmi mais absolument indispensable
concis pratico pratique il n'a pu
absolument pas dans la stratégie
scientifique vaccinale n'ont eu aucune
décision à prendre
en matière de public prioritaire par
exemple toutes les grandes décisions de
politiques publiques relève des miss à
la santé re sur la base de
recommandations d'autorité scientifique
indépendante vous savez on est vraiment
dans le pur opérationnelle bien alors on
sommes pas loin de 30 questions monsieur
le rapporteur général
merci au président sur le ministre tous
mes voeux d'ailleurs vous accompagne
vous le savez et ma question est
relativement bref j'ai pas revenir
longuement sur la stratégie
je lis je bornes simplement incitées
lopes l'opex tki l'office parlementaire
d'évaluation des choix scientifiques je
rappelle pour les nouveaux qui est
partagé entre députés sénateurs et
qu'ils aient dominé plus tôt par
l'opposition d'un présidé par monsieur
dees a dit son vice président gérard
longuet que dit cet office c'est que la
stratégie surtout depuis qu'elle a été
corrigée avec notamment l'ouverture de
la vaccination soignant est une
stratégie qui les satisfait est
satisfaisant
gérard longuet a bien ajouté a même
ajouté êtes vous sûr que ceux qui ne
sont pas au gouvernement aurait été
forcément plus malin que ce qu'ils sont
mais ma question ce n'est pas d'en
rajouter à ce sujet mais plutôt de vous
poser une question qui nous préoccupe
tous maintenant que la stratégie est en
place s'agit d'avoir un planning de
vaccination
on connaît on a tous vu effectivement et
vous avez évoqué effectivement plusieurs
fois les différents vaccins qui vont
normalement approvisionnées
effectivement les hôpitaux et les
centres de vaccination est ce
qu'aujourd'hui
compte tenu de l'ouverture dès demain au
plus de 75 ans de la vaccination y sont
ne plus de 9 millions en france de 75
ans est ce que vous êtes certain il va
pas y avoir un bug
on sent très nettement aujourd'hui que
la population a envie d'être vacciné
beaucoup plus qu'il n'y a simplement vie
jours est ce que vous êtes en mesure de
nous garantir que pour pâques tous les
plus de 75 ans qui le souhaiteront
pourront être vaccinés merci merci
monsieur le rapporteur général d'avoir
rappelé la vie de l'opex qui a fait un
très gros travail et auxquels nous avons
participé humblement côté gouvernement
en terme de l'audition est d'abord de
documents et la ville au texte compte
beaucoup pour moi en tout cas
extrêmement précieux monsieur le
sénateur monsieur rapporteur général
nous ouvrons effectivement la
vaccination à 5 millions de personnes
deux français âgés de 75 ans et plus ils
sont 5 millions et nous nous donnons
évidemment plusieurs semaines pour
pouvoir les vacciner puisque nous
n'avons pas à date et vous le savez 5
millions de vaccins en coffre ou en
congélateur plus tôt nous disposons d'un
million de vaccins 500000 son livre et
autres cet après midi demain
supplémentaires ce qui porte à 1 million
et demi mais incluant les cibles
prioritaires dans les ehpad
mais également les soignantes 50 ans et
plus et donc le rythme des livraisons va
s'accroître semaine après semaine ils
étaient hebdomadaire et donc nous
prévoyons une vaccination qui prendra
plusieurs semaines de la même manière ce
n'est pas parce que nous ouvrons jeudi
la possibilité pour les personnes qui le
souhaitent de prendre rendez-vous en
ligne ou par téléphone que tout le monde
aura immédiatement un rendez vous dans
les prochains jours et c'est je crois
que c'est fondamental de le dire ouvrir
l'accès à la vaccination pour les
personnes de 75 ans et plus en ville ça
ne veut pas dire vacciner tout le monde
d'un coup et donc ce sera lille à des
milliers de professionnels de santé qui
ont mobilisé des centaines de centres de
vaccination qui sont opérationnelles sur
tout le territoire national j'imagine
qu'on y reviendra tout à l'heure donc ce
n'est pas ce n'est pas l'élément
freinant et nous vaccinerons au maximum
de nos capacités le maximum de personnes
cela prendra effectivement du temps
j'espère que pour pâques oui nous aurons
terminé de vacciner en tout cas d'avoir
proposer la vaccination à ses cinq
millions de personnes et même que nous
aurons commencé à proposer la
vaccination à d'autres français par
tranche d'âge toujours vous le savez
cela dépendra également de la validation
ou non
mais j'espère de la validation par les
autorités sanitaires européennes
d'autres vaccins à venir dont nous
pourrions disposer en quantité plus
importante
je ne vais en citer qu'un qui est le
vaccin astrazeneca par exemple qui s'il
était validé d'ici à février nous
permettrait de renforcer nos stocks de 3
millions pour février puis de 6 millions
supplémentaires en mars puis à nouveau
de 4 millions pour avril etc etc
donc nous avons potentiellement 77
millions de doses livrés avant la fin du
mois de juin pour la france 77 millions
de doses vous imaginez donc la
proposition vaccinale que cela
représente pour six mois ce sera une
montée en puissance progressive qui ne
doit rien à la logistique on le dit ici
mais aux commandes qui ont été passées
par la commission européenne depuis
plusieurs mois maintenant et qui nous
seront livrés progressivement très bien
corinne imbert
merci la présidente monsieur ministre
merci d'être au sénat cet après midi
alors après les différentes pénurie
rencontrés depuis bientôt un an nous
voyons bien votre soucis et vous venez
de le dire par rapport aux doses
commandées votre souci de gérer le flux
de vaccins livrés sur le territoire
national afin justement ne pas avoir à
gérer une pénurie supplémentaires
j'aurais voulu trois points des coups
une fois ont constitué le vaccin de
chefa isr biotech présente un volume de
2,25 me l'élite
je ne ferai pas le petit exercice de
calcul que vous connaissez nos
laboratoires disait qu'on pouvait
utiliser cinq doses par flacon vous avez
autorisé l'utilisation d'une sixième dos
ce week-end puisque en fait le plat
qu'on contient cette dose est mis et
c'est une bonne chose parce que si dans
un lot de 5 c 20 % de patients
potentiellement vacciner suppléant en
plus
sachant que cette dose prélevées au lieu
de 5 ça ferait 40 % de patients plus
pourquoi ne pas autoriser la 7e dose
prélevés pour gratiner plus de patients
avec un même sac ont reconstitué
autre autre question le laboratoire
affirme dans le document qu'il a publié
début décembre 1 8 décembre qu'il ne
dispose d'aucune donnée sur
l'interchangeabilité du vaccin de chez
pfizer avec d'autres vaccins contre la
copie de 19
avez vous à ce jour une réponse à cette
question de la terre change habilité et
puis enfin quelle place pensez vous
donner aux différents professionnels de
santé de ville
médecins infirmiers biologistes
pharmaciens dans cette campagne de
vaccination qui prendra qui va aller
vers les personnes de plus de 75 ans
parce que je ne suis pas sûr que là la
réponse d'un centre de vaccination pour
les personnes de plus de 75 ans tels
qu'ils vont être mis en place dans les
départements à partir la semaine
prochaine soit l'unique réponse à
apporter parce que les personnes de plus
de 75 ans à domicile qui ne pourront pas
et placé donc comment vous envisagez
d'associer les professionnels de ville
dans cette campagne de vaccination dans
une logique de proximité
trois questions ça
trois réponses rapides mais maintenant
c'est la triste que je sache la 6e dose
effectivement été autorisé par l'agencé
médicament européenne c'est tant mieux
mais même sans attendre l'autorisation
les problèmes de santé qui s'était rendu
compte qu'il y avait la possibilité de
prélever une sixième d'autres l'avaient
fait je vous rassure
cette dose même la sénatrice ce serait
vraiment une est absolument exceptionnel
de tous les retours que nous avons des
pratiques française européenne et même
mondiale
certains ont fait état de certains
flacons dans lesquelles il y avait même
une septième dose c'est absolument pas
la règle je vous assure là dessus et là
c'est d'ailleurs parce que s'il y avait
cette dose ce serait formidable
on gagnerait effectivement comme vous
l'avez dit 40% l'interchangeabilité non
la personne qui recevra un vaccin en
première section recevra le même vaccin
lors de son rappel vaccinal c'était
important
et puis sur la prise en charge ou plutôt
l'organisation de la vaccination pour
les personnes âgées isolées et bien
c'est au territoire qu'il revient de
s'organiser
alors là je suis très vive rondins en la
matière et je me suis entretenu avec les
associations d'élus pas plus tard que en
début d'après midi il y avait là et reif
l'adf la mf trans'urbaines j'ai constaté
sur les territoires d'ailleurs que déjà
l'innovation avait été mise en place des
binômes se sont constitués médecins
infirmiers pour les vacciner des
personnes âgées des collectivités m'ont
dit monsieur le ministre est ce qu'on a
le droit de prévoir d'organiser le
transport
individuels ou collectifs de personnes
âgées isolées qu'on connaît qu'on a
identifié dans notre fichier canicule et
on sait qu'elles ne pourront pas se
déplacer dans des centres pour les
amener à se faire vacciner évidemment
évidemment évidemment c'est du bon sens
et le bon sens doit prévaloir
donc nous faisons appel à toutes les
bonnes volontés ce que je dis aux
représentants des élus depuis plusieurs
semaines et je leur fais confiance et je
sais qu'ils sont extrêmement mobilisés
aux côtés des professionnels même
d'autres modalités
j'ai cité tout à l'heure l'exemple
grenoblois un exemple qui est magnifique
les gants grenoble c'est la plus belle
du monde comme chacun sait madame
nathalie mais plus sérieusement avec en
lien avec le conseil de l'ordre des
médecins qu'ils organisaient de
vaccination en soirée avec des créneaux
horaires
après 18 heures jusque très tard le soir
pour les libéraux qui travaille toute la
journée et qui ne pouvait pas s'arrêter
de travailler pour les services signer
donc toutes les innovations seront
bonnes
il faut absolument soutenir les
personnes âgées et enfin la quatrième
question qui était caché dans la
troisième à laquelle je répond néanmoins
qui est oui nous voulons compter sur
tous les professionnels de santé pour
vacciner qu'ils soient étudiants ou
retraités c'est déjà le cas aujourd'hui
un décret autorise cela et demain
lorsque nous aurons des vaccins plus
simple ne se stocke pas dans des
congélateurs à -70 qui ne sont pas à
utiliser dans les quatre ou cinq jours
et qui peuvent voyager plus de douze
heures sans casser des bruns des irm
lorsque nous aurons ces vaccins plus
simple j'espère vivement que nous
pourrons nous appuyer sur le réseau des
officines de wismes les médecins
libéraux des infirmiers tous les
soignants qui peuvent vacciner on sait
faire dans notre pays on a le
savoir-faire pour la grippe on vaccine 5
millions de français en une semaine
il n'y a pas de raison qu'on n'y arrive
pas avec un vaccin qui serait
d'utilisation identiques
merci monsieur ministre bernard jomier
merci madame la présidente je voudrais
revenir sur la question de calendrier
parce que l essentiel la stratégie
vaccinale on en a débattu le 17 décembre
dans l'hémicycle et d'ailleurs vous avez
recueilli un large soutien
je veux dire de l'hémicycle à cette
stratégie qui consiste à cibler d'abord
les personnes vulnérables celles qui ce
qui risque de saturer le système
hospitalier et leurs animations qui
risquent de mourir du coc vide pour en
mettant à l'abri ces personnes à la fois
sauver des vies et permettent à notre
société de reprendre ses activités ses
14 à 15 millions de personnes et
comprenez qu'on ait un doute sur le
calendrier de protection de ces
personnes
le premier calendrier qui a été indiqué
au mois de novembre décembre dans les
documents de la has et autres visées la
mise à l'abri laviec vaccination de ces
personnes au premier trimestre puis la d
la campagne a démarré très lentement et
donc on s'est dit ça ne va pas être
possible ça va pas être le premier
trimestre là vous venez de nous dire
qu'on aurait au premier semestre
77 millions de doses il en faut 25 à 30
simplement pour vacciner ces personnes
vulnérables
ma première question c'est sur le
calendrier est ce que ces 14 ou 15
millions de personnes vulnérables seront
vaccinés à votre avis à la fin du
premier trimestre ou plutôt pendant le
second trimestre c'est très important
parce que ça dit à l'ensemble de nos
compatriotes
en gros le calendrier de faim ou de
régression des mesures de restriction
d'activité est ma deuxième question si
on à 77 millions de doses on dépasse
largement la vaccination des personnes
vulnérables
est ce que dans une seconde étape une
fois que l'on aura mis à l'abri ces
personnes par la vaccination
vous comptez promouvoir une stratégie
non plus de vivre avec le virus mais
d'élimination du virus par la
vaccination de une deux fractions
beaucoup plus importante de la
population
et si oui à quelle échéance je remercie
monsieur le sénateur vous avez
parfaitement raison nous nous visons à
protéger et à vacciner le maximum de
personnes dans le temps le plus court
possible parce que c'est un moyen de
lutter avec efficacité contre cette
pandémie de protéger les populations et
de retrouver le cours de notre vie nous
faisons le choix de protéger en priorité
les personnes qui sont les plus fragiles
face au virus vous l'avez dit vous-même
et donc ce sont ce qu'on appelle des
cibles prioritaires de boîte à sept
vilains le mode aussi dans tout cas les
publics à protéger de façon prioritaire
il ya des zones d'incertitude qui ne
sont pas de nature politique qui sont de
nature scientifique par exemple est-ce
que le vaccin astrazeneca sera validée
par les autorités européennes
s'il laisse que c'est fin janvier est-ce
que c'est fin février
est ce que ces femmes à s'il est est ce
que ce sera décidé à un public âgé ou
est ce que c'est pour un public plutôt
jeune
c'est pas les réponses à ces questions
imaginons que fin janvier astrazeneca
soit validé pour les gens en dessous de
65 ans forcément nous aurions alors
deuxième
parallèle un circuit prioritaire avec
les vaccins destinés aux personnes âgées
qui leur seraient pleinement destinée
toujours pour les protéger mais en même
temps le démarrage d'une campagne de
vaccination de personnes plus jeunes
- aris avec un vaccin qui leur seraient
réservés du fait qu'ils ne seraient pas
indiqué pour des publics mais plus des
plus fragiles vous comprenez je n'ai pas
la réponse à ces questions
puisqu'elles relèvent du verdict des
autorités sanitaires européennes mais
vous confirmer que si tous les vaccins
que nous avons achetés sont validées en
temps et en heure par les autorités
sanitaires
nous aurions alors neuf millions de
vaccins livrés à la fin du mois de
février 21 millions de vaccins livrés la
fin du mois de mars
si nous avons 21 millions de vaccins ça
veut dire que nous aurons pu démarrer la
vaccination d'une dizaine de millions de
français voient pas très loin des 15
dont vous parlez potentiellement et
initier la seconde dose du public avait
commencé à être vaccinés et cela dépend
encore une fois ni du ministre de la
centaine il prit dans la république la
commission européenne mais de l' agence
du médicament européen qui doit nous
dire si oui ou non ces vaccins sont
utilisables dans les délais que nous
espérons les plus courts possibles
voilà j'espère avoir été clair ça te
sera t il est totalement liée à ça et
nous et pardon et la seconde question
l'objectif est de vacciner un maximum de
personnes d'éliminer évidemment
d'éliminer la circulation du virus
d'avoir cette forme d'immunité collet
qui met à nouveau jeu mais quand même
une réserve parce que vous savez que je
ne fais jamais de prédiction et que je
ne vais jamais au delà si je vous disais
mes espérances
on pourrait partager ensemble mais mes
espérances ne compte pas je sais ce que
je ne sais pas aussi à date je ne sais
pas à date
ces vaccins ou d'autres trésors de la
contamination s'il préserve uniquement
des formes graves
j'ai des raisons d'espérer monsieur le
sénateur et je sais que vous êtes
médecin et érudit que vous regardez les
études scientifiques et donc vous savez
comme moi que le modern a donc le
pasteur n'y a pas de raison qu'il ya un
mécanisme différent commence à montrer
des signes de réduction des
contaminations
ce qui serait une formidable nouvelle
qui serait une formidable nouvelle
ce serait alors l'occasion l'opportunité
pour l'homme de reprendre le contrôle
sur un environnement devenu hostile
oui merci monsieur le ministre merci
madame la présidente vous avez répondu
sur le volume des doses
donc je vais préciser ma ma question la
vie
de livraison du volume des doses est-ce
qu'elle dépend uniquement de la capacité
de production des laboratoires ou est-ce
qu'elle dépend aussi du prix des vaccins
qui est extrêmement variable d'un vaccin
à un autre sachant que c'est la
commission européenne qui fait les
commandes vous nous l'avez indiqué jour
merci je vais utiliser une expression
populaire on ne met pas tous nos oeufs
dans le même panier
et lorsque les commandes ont été passées
avant l'été dernier par la commission
européenne
c'était des commandes virtuelles auprès
de laboratoires qui commençait à avancer
sur le chemin de la découverte d'un
vaccin sans que nous disposions des - de
donner à la vague à la vague
certains pays ont fait le choix
d'ailleurs de ne commander car seul
vaccin je vous cite un pays non pas pour
les pointer du doigt et c'est tout à
fait leur droit mais on l'a souvent cité
en exemple l'accord et la corée
n'acheter que de l'astra aînés car ils
n'ont pas acheté de fighter savez vous
combien de coréens ont été vaccinées à
ce jour aucun la campagne vaccinale n'a
pas commencé elle ne commencera pas
avant la fin du mois prochain très
probablement c'est leur choix mais ils
ont on a eu un atout en france détrompez
vous il y a des cas qui augmente encore
et l'épidémie l'espagne joue pour
pointer du doigt nous on a eu une chance
en france c'est que nous ne sommes pas
un et 27
et quand nous avons mis en place un
consortium de quatre pays l'italie
l'allemagne les pays bas et la france et
que nous avons commencé à
contractualiser avec des laboratoires
laurent vous avez un vaccin qui pourrait
nous intéresser
on voudrait vous en achetez vous ont
commandé la commission européenne nous a
dit laissez nous faire on va prendre
entre guillemets cet enjeu là on va
précommandée à l'échelle européenne ça
nous permet d'acheter par centaines de
millions de doses et donc de fait de
devenir prioritaires par rapport à
d'autres états je ne sais pas si c'est
si c'est bien ou non en tous les cas sa
garantie à l'europe de disposer de plus
de dos cadenas d'habitants et surtout
d'avoir pu diversifier ses commandes
auprès des principaux laboratoires
disposant d'une mm ou dont on espère
qu'elle disposera d'une m
donc le prix si vous voulez il a été le
reflet de cette capacité cette puissance
à négocier des fortes doses
d'autres pays ont fait le choix de se
lancer dans l'aventuré avec un seul
laboratoire certains avec succès pour
réciter israël d'autres pays ont fait
des choix de se lancer dans l'aventuré
avec un seul laboratoire et ne sont pas
près de commencer leur vaccination
on n'est pas le savary merci oui
monsieur le ministre parce que les gens
s'impatientent et donc ce que je voulais
savoir c'est j'ai appris ce matin dans
le on a le local que la livraison au chu
de reims à l'aide des vaccins à modern
hommes et qui allait remplacer la
livraison des vaccins finder donc je
voulais savoir si c'était en complément
ou pas et surtout une question qui me
préoccupe
chers confrères c'est le passage à six
semaines de la deuxième vaccination au
lieu de trois semaines sur quelles bases
scientifiques vous fondez-vous pour
avancer ce décalage
première question trouver réponse simple
c'est en complément monsieur le sénateur
et voyez ça plutôt comme un geste fait à
destination des communes des villes des
territoires dans lesquels le virus
circule beaucoup ces territoires
notamment du grand test mais aussi de
bourgogne franche comté et puis nice
nous avons décidé de déployer les
cinquante mille premières doses de
vaccin moderna en plus en plus des
livraisons de pfizer et pas au lieu de
50 mille vaccin si on avait fait un
dispatching national ça n'aurait pas eu
de sens donc il fallait nous concentrer
nous concentrons nos forces là où le
virus circule le plus pour protéger le
plus vite possible les personnes
fragiles dans ces territoires
je pense que vous en serez satisfait
après avoir entendu ma réponse sur la
question de la deuxième injection ça
c'est une question qui est qui est tout
à fait intéressant vous savez que nous
avons laboratoires ont dit la deuxième
injection pour le bac neither se fait
entre 21 et 28 jours donc on peut le
faire à quatre semaines après la
première injection
mais l'agencé du médicament européenne
dans ses recommandations a dit on peut
aussi pousser jusqu'à 42 jours parce
qu'on n'a pas de raison de penser que ce
soit - l' agence nationale de sécurité
du médicament dont on dit souvent
qu'elle est frileuse et très attentive
et c est de fait n'est pas frileuse mais
très attentive à 10 20 50 de situation
c'est pas gênant si on utilise la
deuxième injection jusqu'à 42 jours au
lieu de sévir six semaines au lieu de
quatre semaines certains pays l'ont déjà
entériné de manière en routine je pense
au canada par exemple je pense également
au danemark l'angleterre elle a fait un
choix de repousser la deuxième dose même
beaucoup plus loin que le stage quelques
semaines je crois de mémoire
et donc il ya une saisine de la haute
autorité de santé une saisine de la
haute autorité de santé qui doit nous
dire si de son côté elle estime que
cette cette pratique qui consisterait à
différer de quatre à six semaines la
deuxième injection est une pratique
qu'il faut entériner en règle régulière
ou est ce que c'est une pratique qui
peut être proposé dans certaines
situations
c'est là toute la différence j'ai besoin
de l'avis définitif de cette autorité
sachez néanmoins que s'agissant des
ehpad genou désert ont fait le choix de
conserver le rythme de livraison de la
deuxième dose trois semaines après la
première sur dur même pas quatre
semaines mais trois semaines mais je
redis dans la vie de l' agence du
médicament européenne il nous dit que 3
4 à 6 semaines après la première
injection peut être réalisé la seconde
sur les bases monsieur de sénateurs des
analyses des datas scientifique des
études qui ont été faites des réactions
et des effets enregistrés chez les
patients qui ont reçu ce vaccin à trois
quatre ou six semaines
si l' agence du médicament européenne
telle agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament française si bien direction
générale de la santé
et si un certain nombre d'états ont déjà
pris le parti de passer à six semaines
c'est que vraisemblablement l'analyse
scientifique des données je n'en n'ai
pas la compétence comme ministre a
montré que c'était possible
oui enfin mais je n'ai pas la règle que
nous adoptons à ce stade s'est dit que
c'était j'ai dit que c'était possible
mais ce n'est pas pratique le sait mais
il ya déjà des cas où on a des cas de
gens qui se sont fait vacciner il y en a
dans un salaire et à qui on a dit vous
revenez dans six semaines
c'est une possibilité la présidente de
commission qui est conférée il y à une
prière possibilité qui est conférée je
vous le redis s'agissant des ehpad par
exemple c'est trois semaines après la
première injection corelio la seconde et
ensuite la pratique permet de passer de
4 5 ou 6 semaines et nous verrons ce que
dira la haute autorité de santé à savoir
est ce qu'il nous dit pas c'est
systématiquement à six semaines
ou est-ce que c'est réservé à des
situations sous la veste sous la
décision locale et gagne en a donné
rendez-vous ainsi semaines n'ont pas
partie des pad mais ça a été dit ça a
été six semaines voilà bon écoutez on
verra bien
christiane bonfanti dossat
monsieur le ministre parmi les critiques
les plus fréquentes à l'encontre de la
stratégie vaccinale on relève la seule
prise en compte des critères éthiques et
sanitaires au détriment des aspects
logistiques d'ailleurs alain fischer a
déclaré il n'ya pas longtemps et il a
confié qu'il n'était pas du tout aux
spécialistes de ces questions ni
d'organisation ni de transport ni de
livraison et mon département du
lot-et-garonne n'échappe pas à ces
difficultés identifiées à l'échelle
nationale alors vous m'avez rassurer
tout à l'heure lorsque vous avez dit que
les élus locaux seraient maintenant
concernés c'est une bonne nouvelle mais
mon territoire
à l'image du reste de la france restent
insatisfaits désemparés devant
l'impréparation qui caresse caractérise
la stratégie de vaccination des français
et nous avons à cet effet des réunions
avec le préfet une fois par semaine et
celle que nous avons eue hier matin
n'était pas très optimale le
lot-et-garonne à la spécificité de faire
face à une double difficulté
en l'état actuel des choses les doses de
vaccin demeure insuffisante si bien que
les congélateurs prêt à recevoir des
injections reste majoritairement vides
alors en admettant que l'état remplisse
pleinement son rôle et puissent
s'approvisionner mon territoire
rapidement une difficulté plus
structurelles se poserait alors qui va
vacciner le lot-et-garonne comme
beaucoup d'autres départements français
compte des déserts médicaux et plus
généralement une tension élevée entre
offre et demande
les médecins généralistes sont déjà
saturés par la demande des soins
est-ce qu'ils auront assez de temps pour
libérer pour vacciner leurs patients
vous venez de dire et j'en suis ravi que
les médecins généralistes retraités pour
homme pour homme aussi vacciner c'était
la demande faite par le conseil de
l'ordre du lot-et-garonne mais avez vous
envisagé des solutions annexes pour
fluidifier la vaccination dans les
territoires ruraux
je vous assure nous connaissons des
difficultés majeures
merci monsieur merci madame bonfanti
jeunesse
la sénatrice la ruralité fait tellement
partie de nos priorités que j'ai fait un
choix qui est un choix différent celui
de nos voisins qui de ne pas prendre de
ne pas aller vers 50 vaccinodromes à
l'échelle du pays mais à des centaines
de petits centres de vaccination à
l'échelle des territoires avec je le
redis à terme 5 à 7 centres de
vaccination par département jeudi à
terme mais certains départements ont
déjà dépassé allègrement le quota fixé
assistante ou sept centres et j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire au préfet et aux
directions générales des ars que
plusieurs centres c'est parce qu'il ya
plus de 100 qu'il y aura plus de vaccins
alloués aux départements et si je me
permettais madame la sénatrice
je reçois déjà des demandes d'élus qui
me disent je veux plus de vaccins pour
mon territoire
je vous je le dis tout net la maçonnerie
la répartition des vaccins par
territoire et les données de façon
hebdomadaire après concertation avec les
équipes sanitaires en fonction des
besoins et en faisant juste répartition
à l'échelle de la nation
les vaccins dont nous disposons à mesure
que nous en disposons mais ce n'est pas
parce qu'un élu me dira j'ai pas assez
de vaccins dans mon congélateur il m'en
faut plus qu'on va on enlevait en
départements voisins pour lui redonner
aux siens vous le comprendrez ce qui
n'empêche pas son téléphone de fumer ou
presque certains jours park est sous le
coup des demandes des élus d'avoir un
maximum de vaccin ce qui est une
démarche compréhensible ce qui montre
aussi que les élus sont très mobilisés
et je m'en félicite
j'étais pas dans le lot-et-garonne
madame la sénatrice mais j'étais à
tarbes samedi dernier avec le premier
ministre et j'ai vu un maire un
président de département et présidente
de région mobilise et mettant en place
déjà des équipes notamment l'équipe
soignante du des équipes départementales
pour elle venir en aide aux et pas de
recul et des élus mobilisés qui ont
développé des centres de vaccination et
des médecins libéraux des infirmières
des médecins de ville les choses les
choses se déroulent bien avec
l'engagement de chacun je crois vraiment
que tout le monde a sa place et que nous
ne fixons aucune limite dans la capacité
des élus à agir pour fluidifier les
choses et organiser les centres de
vaccination je crois profondément que
c'est la clé du succès et je crois que
ça va dans le sens d'ailleurs de ce que
vous m'aviez demandé lors du débat
parlementaire pourrait citer trois
centres de vaccination il faut un acte
d'achat
madame la sénatrice j'ai annoncé qu'il
objectif c'était qu'il y ait un centre
par département la semaine dernière
trois centres par département à la fin
de cette semaine et jusqu'à six centres
à la fin du mois par département nous
sommes déjà à plus de 200 centres
ouverts le mardi de la deuxième semaine
je n'ai pas peur de manquer de sens j'ai
plutôt la crainte qu'il sort développe
un peu trop et que ça fasse autant de
centres qui se répartissent des doses de
vaccins qui dans les premiers temps ne
permettront pas à chaque centre de tenir
toute une semaine avant la prochaine
livraison ce pourquoi j'attire votre
attention président milan président
milan oui merci madame la présidente
monsieur ministre l'ensemble de nos
collègues à juste raison est intéressé
par la protection de la population
donc moi je ne m'opposerai pas de
questions sur ce sujet puisque toutes
les questions sont déjà posés ou
quasiment tout
je vais vous poser une question sur la
protection d'environnement c'est à dire
dans le cadre de la stratégie vaccinale
quelles sont les recommandations potel
mise en place
quant à la collecte et au traitement des
déchets six consécutifs à la réalisation
eh bien figurez-vous on nous reproche
parfois monsieur le sénateur pas vous
mais ça arrive d'envoyer des documents
copieux goûter aux autres pour justement
mettre établir un certain nombre de
règles de bonnes pratiques et où qu'il
existe un document un cahier des charges
qui a été envoyée aux préfets aux ars et
qui est bien sûr très productif pour
chaque centre de vaccination et qui
comporte un chapitre dédié je le cite
haut à la gestion des dasri c'est à dire
des déchets d'origine médicale avec une
responsabilités conférées aux hôpitaux
pigeons au centre de tout en matière de
traitement des déchets donc on n'y a
pensé les merci de votre question
laurence cohen oui merci madame la
présidente merci monsieur le ministre
beaucoup de questions ont été posées
donc moi je vais revenir sur les les
questions de logistique parce que
effectivement il semble que ce soit un
problème épineux dans notre pays ça a
été vrai pour les masses pour les tests
et on sent encore aujourd'hui au niveau
de la vaccination
et c'est d'ailleurs à mon sens le fait
que le
la logistique publique d'état et était
quand même démantelé et pas par votre
gouvernement mais avant quiconque qui
vous conduit sans doute à faire appel à
un cabinet de conseil de stratégie un
cabinet privé vous fait appel donc à ce
cabinet mckinsey c'est l'un des plus
grands du monde avec près de 10
milliards de dollars de chiffre
d'affaires et bon effectivement les
services sont quand même facture et il
faut le dire 130000 euros la semaine
donc je voudrais savoir finalement sur
quel budget cet argent va être pris
c'est à dire est ce que ça va dépendre
des du budget du ministère de la santé
ou de l'elysée directement ou bien
est-ce que ça va être pris sur le budget
de la sécurité sociale crois que c'est
très important que nous le sachions au
niveau de la commission des affaires
sociales et je vous en remercie par
avance la sénatrice le budget de
financement et plus sûrement le budget
mon ministère donc le budget du
ministère de la santé et des solidarités
d'attenté certainement pas sur le budget
de la sécurité sociale et je encore une
fois je revendique que me soyons
capables que nous soyons capables de
nous et de nous épauler sur toutes les
compétences ou qu'elle existe il ya par
exemple un général qui est en charge de
la logistique au sein du ministère il ya
deux lieutenants colonels qui y
travaillent
il y a plusieurs visages de logisticiens
certains sont venus d'ailleurs nous
épauler bénévolement d'autres ont été
recrutés chez maman sarah sur konvict un
général à la tête de la logistique
audrey que nous devons réagir bien sûr
bien sûr nous faisons appel à toutes les
compétences ans qu'elle existe et
heureusement nous en avons beaucoup dans
le secteur public je voudrais dire
pardon mais j'en profite à chaque fois
je voudrais les remercier ces personnes
parce que derrière le mot
technostructure administration derrière
toutes ces personnes c'est en fait ce
sont des milliers de personnes qui se
sentent parfois pointé du doigt alors
qu'elles consacrent absolument toute
leur énergie qu'elle travaille au sein
du ministère
en dehors du ministère dans une agence
régionale ou nationale ou qu'elle
travaille dans le secteur privé qu'elle
soit venu nous épauler ou qu'elle vient
des armes et autres ce sont des gens je
vous assure si vous veniez les voir avec
moi ce sont des gens qui travaillent en
permanence et qui travaillent en réseau
et qui travaille bien
le challenge est absolument immense ne
chantait la logistique dans notre pays
est immense je ne dis pas que nous avons
toutes les compétences et que et que
chose coule de source effectivement et
je ne suis pas sûr que la france soit le
pays le plus équipé à la base en termes
logistiques mais je vous dis qu on a des
ressources absolument absolument
admirable et ce sont des gens qui
parfois se sentent incriminés quand il
ya des critiques bien davantage
d'ailleurs que que le politique lui même
qui ont besoin qu'on les soutienne donc
je dis à mes équipes que je vais
remercier que je les soutiens
bernard bonne oui monsieur mais par
rapport à ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure effectivement moi je voudrais
poser la question des femmes 30%
je crois qu'il faut absolument
aujourd'hui par rapport à ce que vous
aviez vous avez dit dans le calendrier
vaccinal qu'il faut optimiser au maximum
des doses qui sont donnés aux
différentes personnes or les médias
comme le gouvernement du reste parle des
30% qui risque d'être perdu dans le
cadre de la vaccination est ce qu'il ne
serait pas possible dans tous les
centres qui sont nombreux de vaccination
de permettre lorsque l'utilisation n'est
pas totale des flacons soit parce qu'il
ya trop soit parce que les doses ne sont
pas toutes utilisées de permettait des
personnes ne permettent à des personnes
de venir
même sans critère d'âge d'autres choses
pour se faire vacciner profiter des
vaccins avant qu'il ne soit perdu mais
sept sénateurs
je vous remercie votre question ce n'est
pas la première fois que j'entends mais
ce type de questions me fait me fait
penser on pourrait considérer que par a
priori ne manquerions de bon sens voit
que nous pourrions manqué de bon sens et
que les médecins les pharmaciens les
infirmiers pourrait manquer de bon sens
il n'y a pas besoin de consignes écrites
ou deux mots d'ordre pour que quelqu'un
ne jette pas à flacons dans lequel il
resterait une ou deux doses à la fin de
la journée de vaccination et qu'ils
vaccinent les personnes qui se trouvent
autour
nous les avons malgré tout écrit de ses
consignes monsieur le sénateur dans un
célèbre dans un guide devenu célèbre
pour bien rappeler notamment dans les
ehpad que s'il n'y a plus de candidats à
la vaccination qui répondent aux
critères et bien tout candidat
disponible sur place doit évidemment se
faire proposer le vaccin nous ne voulons
pas rejeter le taux de 30% qui est un
taux théorique de pertes liées au
transport à l'usagé etc
nous n'en sommes ne sommes aujourd'hui
très loin je touche du bois
il nous reste
longues semaines nous sommes à ce stade
très très loin de ce taux de pertes ce
qui est une excellente nouvelle puisque
quelques unités taux de pertes ce qui ce
qui semble effectivement très peu
aujourd'hui
signe que 1 tout le monde progresse et
deux couteaux ont fait très attention à
ce vaccin qui est un bien précieux
le problème c'est que la population soit
averti justement de la possibilité de se
faire vacciner
il faut soit là vous savez on parle de
une ou deux doses qu'ils resteraient
dans un flacon ouvert on ne fait pas un
appel à la population fin je me vois mal
faire un appel à la population leur
disant rôder autour de nepad à 15h06
jamais reste une ou deux doses
vous avez vous avez des soignants qui
sont âgés de moins de 50 ans vous avez
de la famille qui peut être présentes
vous avez l'animateur local de l'ehpad
enfin vous avez je vous assure qu'ils
trouvent il ya je n'ai aucune je n'ai
aucune remontée de soigner en me disant
on a fini la journée de boulot on va
jeter du vaccin ce qu'on a trouvé
personne donc voilà c'est ça se fait
c'est en marge
c'est une toute petite fraction de la
vaccination mais évidemment nous ne
voulons pas ajouter de doses de vaccins
madame poncet long jeu rouge s'explique
merci madame la présidente monsieur
ministre tout d'abord je rappelais
effectivement le soutient la stratégie
vaccinale qui peut-être aussi est un
facteur de lenteur de la montée en
charge
on vaccine d'abord les milliers d pad
sur le territoire vite dire que
effectivement on a vu l'accélération de
des publics prioritaires notamment des
aides à domicile qui a été très saluée
il reste cependant les bénévoles ni
l'ensemble des établissements médico
sociaux qui ne sont pas encore cité dans
les populations cibles
le dom le demande et si effectivement
les acteurs associatifs qui agissent
auprès de ces publics
mon ma question porte sur l'accès au
vaccin
l'accès au vaccin qui est un marché
régulé 1 par l'union européenne vous en
avait parlé
la france reçoit donc sont son quota
générationnel sont des vaccins que nous
avons précommander que l'europe a pris
commande et dans le cadre des
informations régionales la semaine
dernière donnée auprès des élus il a été
mentionné que certains pays européens en
retard logistique peut-être que nous
libère enfin
on libérer des quantités résiduelles ces
quantités je voudrais savoir sont-elles
réguler elle aussi par l'europe selon
les mêmes critères générationnel et si
ce n'est pas le cas le parlement mais
aussi le public doit avoir accès aux
contrats d'achats directs français
si c'est le cas et à leurs conditions et
prix vous engagez vous monsieur le
ministre à la transparence sur ces
contrats comme le demandent par ailleurs
l'office parlementaire d'évaluation des
choix scientifiques et technologiques
par la mise en place notamment c'est une
proposition d'un registre public des
contrats signés plus un contrôle a
posteriori vous l'avez compris monsieur
le ministre ces questions portent sur la
transparence et c'est un facteur de
confiance des élus et de la population
qui dépend le succès de notre stratégie
vaccinale
madame la sénatrice lorsque la
commission européenne et ça lui arrive
de le faire et c'est tant mieux
doit passer de nouveaux contrats avec
des laboratoires pour lequel elle avait
déjà pré commandé des doses la règle
simple qu'ils s'impliquent est la même
c'est à dire que chaque pays se voient
proposer la possibilité de commander des
vaccins au prorata de sa population au
sein de l'europe
une règle d'équité si jamais des pays
un ou plusieurs pays refuse d'acquérir
les doses qui leur correspondent
alors cette dose peuvent être mises à
nouveau à répartition pour les pays qui
le souhaiterait qu'ils faudraient et qui
voudra l'acheter la france est
extrêmement attentive vous le dire
extrêmement attentif à ce que chaque
pays se voit respecter et respecte
lui-même cette règle tacite importante
d'équité au sein de l'union européenne
c est moyen mais laurent blanc va oui ça
fait ainsi à des contrats donc d'achat
direct de ccc quantité résiduelle est ce
que c'est les contrastes seront rendus
publics et toulouse où il n'y a pas de
contrat d'achat direct au sein de
l'union européenne
les règles sont très claires ce sont
uniquement des marchés passés par la
commission européenne
et c'est la commission européenne
elle-même qui assurent le dispatching au
sein des pays de l'union européenne tout
est transparent et votée par les
parlementaires européens en terme de
règles de fonctionnement
laurent gerra oui merci madame la
présidente monsieur miss je vais être
direct comment ces lettres darrat
dans le gard à matière de stratégie
vaccinale qui décident monsieur le
ministre est ce que c'est le politique
est-ce que c'est l'administration voire
la bureaucratie ou est ce que c'est
trente cinq citoyens qui sont tirés au
sort la politique vaccinale est conduite
par le ministère de la santé
sous la responsabilité du premier
ministre et du présent arrêt public la
stratégie d'acquisition des vaccins est
conduite conjointement par agnès pannier
rue nash est la secrétaire d'état en
charge de l'industrie et par le ministre
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre des
affaires étrangères et de l'europe
clément bonne nous inspirons et nous
suivons les recommandations des
autorités scientifiques indépendantes en
toute transparence nous avons un comité
vaccinale moi je pense que nous sommes
bien outillé avec ces instances qui
fonctionne bien pour mener et conduire
une politique de stratégie néanmoins il
avait été question est d'ailleurs ça va
être une demande je crois qu'ils avaient
été relayées ici au sénat monsieur le
sénateur qu'il y ait de la citoyenneté
de l'intégration citoyenne de la
démocratie sanitaire et le conseil
économique social et environnemental
saisi s'était saisi de cette question là
et avait proposé qu'un tirage au sort de
citoyens soient réalisés qui permettent
de suivre la politique vaccinale tekken
qui menait à ce stade je ne connais pas
les trente ou trente-cinq personnes
tirent au sort je ne sais pas s'ils ont
été tirés au sort mais je vous redis
comment la cour de la conduite de la
politique vaccinale est réalisé dans
notre pays et j'ai l'honneur et la
chance privilège de venir rendre compte
de cette action à échelon réguliers
devant lé parlement c'est ma quatrième
ou cinquième intervention aujourd'hui
devant le parlement où devant des
commissions ou devant des réunions
d'élus je pense que c'est important et
en termes de transparence je crois que
nous avons rempli les critères
véronique guillotin merci à madame la
présidente jus de deux questions la
première concerne la définition des
publics prioritaires
donc j'ai bien compris la hiérarchie des
patients les plus âgés les plus fragiles
en ehpad aurait pas d' et les tranches
d'âge est-ce qu'il serait pas judicieux
puisque je pense qu'on a quand même
aujourd'hui un nombre de vaccins
suffisant me semble-t-il d'intégrer mais
assez rapidement les publics les plus
jeunes mais en fait des publics très
fragilisé je pense notamment aux
patients et
déprimé patients greffés ce type de
patients là est ce qu'il pourrait pas
réintégré cette liste des patients
prioritaire est la deuxième question
c'est plutôt sur les variantes du virus
qui préoccupe tout le monde aujourd'hui
pas seulement parce que le variant
anglais semblent plus contagieux mais
aussi parce que nous pouvons pas exclure
à moyen ou long terme la survenue d'un
virus dont la mutation rendrait moins
efficace voire pas efficace la
vaccination donc déjà sa demande à une
accélération vaccinale pour éviter ce
problème là et maintenant que nous
connaissons cette capacité de mutation
du virus j'aimerais savoir si vous si
notre pays va se lancer va accélérer le
séquençage afin de les dépister et dans
le cas d'un dépistage le cas échéant
quelle va être la politique vaccinale
derrière je peux permettre madame la
sénatrice de deux très importantes
questions vous soulignez la première
c'est l'intégration parmi les publics
prioritaires d'une certaine partie de la
population celles et ceux d'entre nous
n'ont pas 75 ans mais qui souffrent de
maladies qui les expose à des risques de
formidable c'est le professeur alain
fischer qui est chargé de rédiger cette
liste de maladies de comorbidité qu'on
les appelle particulièrement exposés au
risque de formes graves et que nous
intégrerons et que nous ajouterons aux
personnes de 75 ans et plus qui pourront
bénéficier de la vaccination à partir de
lundi prochain
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
français c'est une liste qui n'a pas
l'exhaustivité que certains le
souhaiteraient mais qui une liste qui se
fixe comme critère la rigueur
scientifique quant à l'exposition des
formes graves
on peut imaginer qu'on y trouvera des
patients souffrant des mots pâtit
maligne ou de cancer au cours de
traitement par exemple vous avez posé la
question des greffes d'organes des
greffés d'organes qui sont évidemment au
coeur des préoccupations sanitaires
deuxième question sur le séquençage
oui j'en séquençage la france développe
sous l'égide de frédéric vidal ministre
en charge de la recherche et de
l'innovation des plateformes uniforme
unifiée de séquençage génomique en lien
avec les cnrs du pasteur les ja chu et
laboratoires publics et privés de
manière à augmenter nos capacités de
séquençage génétique pour faire face à
la survenue de variants j'étais hier
avec le professeur lina hier soir assez
tard auxerre bruno lina qui est un
éminent du prologue qui amenait sur les
journées de jeudi et vendredi dernier le
travail qui consiste à colliger
et de milliers de tests pcr réaliser
c'est toujours là en france et de les
faire passer sur ce qu'on appelle une
plateforme thermo fisher qui permet de
suspecter la présence d'un baril à
anglet et ensuite de procéder un
séquençage génétique en bonne et due
forme des classes suspecte il nous
disait hier qu'il trouve à peu près 1%
de variants de nature d'origine anglaise
parmi les pcr positive en france avec
une disparités territoriales dispersion
territoriales qui fait qu'il n'ya pas de
région qui concentrerait de nombreux cas
c'est très intéressante et utile ça
permet de surveiller s'il ya une
croissance de ce variant et de vérifier
s'il devait apparaître des clusters donc
c'est une opération qui sera renouvelée
très régulièrement c'est-à-dire toutes
les 7 à 10 jours environ
chantal de seine ensuite ce sera vite
quand jasmin mais chantal de seine merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre vous avez répondu sur la
calendrier vaccinal
je voudrais vous faire préciser votre
réponse sur le taux de protection du
vaccin est sûr une deuxième injection à
six semaines
quel est donc le taux de protection à
six semaines les scientifiques ne
semblent pas tous d'accord sur la
question
certains affirment que la protection
monte en puissance dans les trois
premières semaines pour atteindre un
palier et éventuellement redescendre
avant après par non et donc une deuxième
injection à six semaines ne permettrait
pas d'obtenir une immunité suffisante
je me suis fait l'écho encore une fois
de l'avis de l'agencé nationale de
sécurité du médicament en charge des
autorisations de mise sur le marché des
médicaments et qui nous dit que si la
deuxième dose du vaccin de pfizer devait
être différée à six semaines cela n'en
porterai pas de conséquence j'ai dit
tout à l'heure une erreur pardonnez moi
j'ai dit que j'avais saisi la haute
autorité de santé de la question aurait
été la haute autorité de santé se saisir
elle même de cette question à travers ce
qu'on appelle la setv qu'est la
commission technique de la vaccination
n'a beaucoup d'autorités sanitaires et
scientifiques qui travaillent sur ces
questions là et donc nous verrons si
elle a fine et précise les choses et
j'ai parlé aussi de la vie de le m&a qui
va dans ce sens je n'ai pas d'autre
commentaire avant que celui ci
enfin dire que j'ai décidé que la
deuxième injection pour les personnes
âgées en ehpad ce serait à trois
semaines et que j'ai ouvert la
possibilité la deuxième injection pour
des personnes par exemple tel que les
soignants de 50 ans et plus puissent se
faire entre 4 et jusqu'à six semaines
si c'était choisi si c'était le choix
local ils sont habilités à le faire là
mêmes encadre les règles de prescription
par les médecins vous commande va pas
sur encadrer les règles de prescription
par rapport à ce que proposent les
agences sanitaires
si demain et je pense que j'aurais
bientôt des recommandations affiné
précisé par la haute autorité de santé
alors je reviendrai vers vous et je vous
dirai voilà voyez ce que nous dit
aujourd'hui la haute autorité de santé
sur quels fondements et voilà quelles
conclusions en tirer très bien victor
jasmin en visio quand mes vidanges ou un
point très bonne année à tous et mon
alim sur le ministre et bien je vous
parle depuis la guadeloupe
je voudrais seulement savoir monsieur
ministre lise hébert les éventuelles
clauses de non recours est ce qu'il
existe
est ce que les différentes firmes qui
ont reçu les autorisations de mise en
2011 sur le marché
on bénéficie de aussi closes là alors
est-ce qu'on peut donner de l'épaisseur
et informations nécessaires je vous
remercie
pardonnez-moi suffisamment avec le son
je vends les clauses de retour
les clubs à l'école excusez moi excusez
moi c'est moi il reste que l'excusé moi
au cas où il y en aurait parce que bon
j'ai entendu dire qu'il y en avait une
qui en avait alors je voulais avoir des
précisions et des informations
concernant ces clauses particulièrement
avec les films qui ont déjà voici les
autorisations de mise sur le marché de
leurs vaccins oui non recours contre le
laboratoire
ah oui d'accord dont il n'y a pas
d'accord de clause de limitation de
responsabilité
il est en tout cas pour les usagers et
bien est ce qu'il y aurait celle-ci
close parce qu'il y avait évidemment des
antiques qui parle de ses coups
d'accords pardon je vous ai compris donc
il n'y a pas de clause de non
responsabilité qui protégerait les
laboratoires on est dans le droit commun
savoir que ces laboratoires
commercialise un produit qui souffre
d'un défaut de fabrication
ou de billets etc le laboratoire on est
entièrement responsable en revanche si
quelqu'un doit présenter un effet
indésirable grave avec des séquelles des
conséquences ou tout autre problème
justifiant qu'il y est un accompagnement
médical voire une prise en charge voire
des indemnisations et qu'il n'y a pas de
faute du laboratoire dans le sens où ce
n'est pas la nature du produit mais
plutôt la réaction ce qu'on appelle un
aléa thérapeutique qui peut intervenir
c'est la solidarité nationale via
l'oniam qui est une caisse qui existe
d'ailleurs comme pour tous les
médicaments tous les vaccins et toute
intervention médicale ou chirurgicale
qui prend en charge et qui dédommage et
indemnise les patients l'oniam pouvant
se retourner d'ailleurs dans de très
rares cas contre le professionnel de
santé qui a effectué l'acte par exemple
s'il ya une faute manifeste non pas une
erreur mais une faute manifeste comme
par exemple quelqu'un qui je sais pas
mme injecterait cinq flacons au lieu
d'une dose dans ce cas là c'est
évidemment pas la solidarité nationale
et une faute manifeste caractérisée mais
sinon notre système est protecteur pour
les soignants et il ne l'est pas pour
les laboratoires martin lévriers on va
on va recommencer vraiment de questions
encore suis désolé mais
temps passe très vite martin lévriers
pas tout le monde en particulier à vous
monsieur le ministre et à travers vous à
tous les personnels soignants deux ans
et tous et administratifs qui
effectivement sont souvent pris pour des
boucs émissaires ce qui ne résout pas
les problèmes
deux questions la presse je suis désolé
mais bien de richard yung le sénateur
des français de l'étranger qui
s'interroge sur les orientations qui
pourraient être définies pour la
vaccination des français établis hors de
france
est ce qu'il y a selon vous est ce qu'il
est ce qu'il y à déjà un travail ce
sujet la houppe un jeu et je rebondis
sur cette question pour poser la même
question pour les étrangers établis en
france active en temps et en heure
française ou d'autres procédures
et enfin dernière question j'ai vu que
des patients ou de prises de rendez vous
médical type d'octo l'iba et là où
d'autres ont été sélectionnés par l'état
pour la phase grand public
est-ce que trop d'informations ou trop
de possibilités ne risque pas de tuer
les possibilités comment cela va être
organisé merci beaucoup merci monsieur
le sénateur lors il ya trois
prestataires effectivement privé kps doc
maya et d'octo libre d'obtenir par
exemple c'est celui qui gère les carnets
de commandes de cary grant et vous pour
l'allemagne notamment berlin donc et
c'est un acteur français donc on a mis
dans le panel des acteurs mais n'est pas
tout seul ils sont trois et il y à un
système national l'uniforme pour les
pour les usagers ne verront pas la
différence puisque ça passe par un site
qui est le site sante.fr qu'il n'est pas
encore actif pour prendre rendez-vous
mais qui le sera ici à jeudi pour les
français de l'étranger c'est comme pour
toute prise en charge et peuvent se
faire vacciner localement s'il ya des
conventions entre la france et des états
dans lesquels ils résident
alors il peut y avoir une prise en
charge des frais et sinon ils peuvent se
faire vacciner en france il rentre dans
les mêmes conditions que n'importe quel
français vivant en france
je crois qu'il ya une troisième question
du sénateur mais je n'ai peut-être mangé
et france à l'étranger en france même
dispositif sept-îles à l'étranger
résidant en france
et bien s'il a une sécurité sociale ou
une convention de sécurité sociale
il est pris en charge et en définitive à
l'étranger peut se faire vacciner sur le
sol français s'ils répondent aux
critères d'ouverture des fichiers
donnant droit à des soins au titre de
n'importe quelle soit madame ferrer est
sûre rapide
alors madame ferrer oui très vite parce
que ça va ça va monsieur le ministre je
voulais revenir rapidement sur le rôle
et la place des élus locaux dans
l'organisation et des commandes de la
campagne cette campagne de vaccination
vous pourriez vous nous dire comment
vous les avez associés et consultés pour
cette organisation
ils sont très demandeurs vous l'avez dit
ils sont prêts à s'investir comme ils
l'ont fait depuis le début de l'épidémie
et vous savez comme nous qu'ils
connaissent parfaitement leur territoire
et leur population
comment peuvent-ils donc faire connaître
aussi leurs besoins et en particulier je
pense
dans mon département du calvados sont un
certain nombre déjà deux centres de
vaccination ont été mis en place mais il
ya entre guillemets comme on dit
familièrement à trous dans la raquette
car un une commune de plus de 8000
habitants ne se voit pas mis en place ce
centre de vaccination et obligerait donc
les populations à faire car en pouvoir
plus une kilomètres pour pouvoir se
faire vacciner
tout cela participe de la proximité et
du lien essentiel et du rôle extrêmement
important de des élus locaux du vous
remercie madame la sénatrice comme j'en
discute avec les élus locaux
régulièrement j'ai fait plusieurs
déplacements joueurs je vais avoir au
moins trois centres de vaccination a
montré trois élus distincts locaux dans
l'est dans les 48 prochaines heures
encore une fois on peut pas avoir un
centre de vaccination partout on veut 5
ou 600 de vaccination par département ce
qui assure comme un bon maillage si les
élus souhaitent organiser des transports
collectifs ou individuels vers des
centres ils peuvent le faire c'est les
élus souhaitent mobiliser les personnes
âgées isolées chez elles dont ils savent
qu'elles sont isolés et chez elle ils
peuvent tout à fait le faire c'est les
élus disposent de personnels de mairie à
mettre à disposition des centres ils
peuvent le faire et d'ailleurs ils le
font si les élus souhaitent participer à
promouvoir la vaccination près de la
population de leur commune ils peuvent
le faire ils sont même invités et
inciter à le faire si les élus
souhaitent identifier des soignants ou
toutes ressources permettant d'enrichir
la campagne vaccinale et y participer
activement ils peuvent le faire les élus
locaux participent aux cellules
départemental de coordination de mise en
place de la vaccination on avec les
préfets les ars les élus locaux ont un
rôle fondamental important est pour
l'instant partout où je suis allé il le
prenait à bras le corps partout dans
chaque centre où je suis allé il y avait
un maire qui étaient présents des élus
ses adjoints qui participent qui
organise qui font la promotion du centre
je crois que c'est encore une fois de ce
fourmillement collectif au delà de
toutes les étiquettes pour ça que je
souhaite vraiment que sur cette campagne
vaccinale au delà des critiques qui
peuvent être tout à fait légitime ou des
des encouragements
quelle que soit leur forme à faire plus
vite mieux ou différemment je crois
qu'il faut qu'on soit soudée comme
jamais dans ce pays il faut qu'on soit
soudée comme jamais nous avons un enjeu
de la confiance majeure qui est devant
nous nous ne pouvons pas être un pays
dans lequel le taux d'adhésion à la
vaccination serait plus faible
qu'ailleurs et je n'y crois pas une
seconde
parce que si les français sont critiques
si les français s'interrogent si les
français réfléchissent avant d'agir en
définitive les français font le bon
choix
eh bien nous devons leur donner
confiance les accompagner vers ce bon
choix et mettre en place chacun à notre
place chacun avec nos compétences nos
rôles nos responsabilités
nos atouts ce qui doit procéder d'une
grande campagne de vaccination pour
notre pays je remercie
voilà nous avions ce temps très
contraint c'est compliqué nous étions
nombreux il ya encore beaucoup de
collègues qui souhaitait poser les
questions de gestion du ciment monsieur
iacovelli je suis d'accord mais enfin
monsieur le ministre si vous devez
respecter l'ordre du 2.2 question aurait
pu peut poser une question d'écouté pas
vrai parce que j'ai essayé justement de
faire tourner dans l'ordre et ce n'est
pas moi qui ai fixé une heure de deux
d'audition donc vous vous arrangez avec
monsieur le ministre
puisque vous êtes vous êtes sénateur
madame la présidente si vous me
permettez je vais aller à la rencontre
des directions des pharmaciens des
médecins des 100 hôpitaux pivot ainsi
que de tous les directeurs généraux des
ars il y aura également de croix des
préfets pour continuer de travailler
avec eux comme je le fais toutes les
semaines
néanmoins je reste à disposition du
parlement et en particulier du sénat je
serai je crois demain pour la séance de
questions au gouvernement s'il y avait
des questions complémentaires et si vous
souhaitez nous adresser des questions il
y à ma collaboratrice ma conseillère en
charge des affaires pas
commentaire que chacun connaît ici qui
me transmettra à vos questions et/ou à
mon équipe et je me fais me fais fort
d'y répondre avec 48 heures voilà donc
ce que je vous propose pour ceux qui
n'ont pas posé de question c'est de me
les adresser celle que vous souhaitiez
posez moi j'avais aussi beaucoup de
questions qui ont été données j'ai
essayé de faire parler en effet en ne
respectant pas forcément l'homme et pour
que tous les groupes s'exprime je suis
vraiment désolé mais c'est un temps très
contraint merci monsieur le ministre
pour des réponses précises à des
questions précises
sachez que nous ne sommes pas dans un
polémique nous souhaitons que la
stratégie réussisse et que le plus grand
nombre de vagues de français qui
souhaitent être vaccinés
le soin voilà